robbing very quickly because pink it's
back to perform but can you just quickly
tell us the story about being in LA and
meeting the gangster yeah so I in Los
Angeles before children I used to have
this house that was just for football at
a football pitch in the back this is so
rock'n'roll yet special special house
for football and then the kids came and
that was the end of that there one
evening playing football and there's a
lot of people up there small Drive
somebody's parked on the drive and my
neighbor can't get his car up the drive
my neighbor is Joey Pesci oh yeah yeah
he buries that's the exact look that he
gave as he turned into the football
pitch with a 9-iron and came out every
new mother it was absolutely terrifying
because you know he does that face so
well I was absolutely mortified and
pretended it wasn't my house Macaulay
Culkin and done all these booby traps I
now I sort of scope her and I get out of
there and the next day I hastily
arranged a sign that says no parking and
I I stick it down so everybody knows
including mr. Joey Pesci sorry May that
you know that I was doing something to
stop this from happening that evening I
went to an Italian restaurant and the
guy came over to me and he went hey I
really like what you did for Joey
so now I'm and like I'm socially awkward
and socially unaware and I'm now proper
[ __ ] myself and watching people as
they leave the restaurant kind of go up
to him and kiss him like this and like
20 people have done it and I don't go to
the loo I'm leaving I think I got must
go the loo I can do it so I go the loo
and I'm coming back and as I'm as I'm
leaving this Italian restaurant we stand
up he stood on some stairs this guy this
gangster dude and I've sort of like was
so nervous I went over to him and just
went